the craggy beauty of Norway's coastline
[Music]
but look closer and you see the horror
colored dots of plastic a year ago I was
here following the story of a whale that
died with plastic in its stomach I
returned to see its legacy a very
special Beach clean these volunteers
have come from a dozen countries
inspired by our documentary to help
ariana came from italy she's overwhelmed
by what she's seen feeling that it is
not clean removing so much plastic needs
heavy lifting gear the Norwegian
government has given 6 million pounds
for the cleanup this year and driving it
all is Kenneth this is not going to stop
now this is a revolution a big
revolution and it will never stop
it will grow each day it will grow so
this movement has started in Bergen with
one whale do you hope that will become
our global movement now yes yes we are
started it and we are going to finish it
I can assure you
but there is much to do a short boat
ride away we found yet more plastic
almost every island in Norway's
archipelago has its own problem Norway's
coastline with all its islands and
fjords stretches for sixty thousand
miles and running just offshore there's
a strong current that sweeps from the
south from the rest of Europe and it
brings an abundance of plastic some of
it from the UK here there's a Lucas a
bottle with a British address on it and
here a fishing crate from the east coast
of England
afros has come halfway around the world
to meet Kennedy who cleans beaches in
Mumbai but the plastic problem has no we
took him further up the coast to another
Island the plastic here is becoming part
of nature this is plastic soup he's
never seen plastic broken down into such
tiny pieces it's far harder to clean up
raise up this far too long waiting for
the government and the law and for the
deposit scheme and the penalty in the
course of action the skeleton of the
whale that started this story has been
cleaned and now needs to be pieced
together it'll be displayed in a local
museum a warning of what our lifestyles
are doing to the environment this was
the reason why we now everyone is
collecting plastic on the beaches
everyone is is saying no thanks when you
offer the plastic bag on the shore the
tide is turning
beaches cleaned habits changed that's
the effect of the plastic whale Thomas
More Sky News in Bergen Norway